[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 hoy viernes tenemos en
nuestro estudio ya como es habitual a la
señorita Marta Moya Marta bienvenida
buena mañana de viernes Gracias Raúl
buenos días bueno el lunes está previsto
que den inicio las negociaciones entre
el gobierno de Colombia y la guerrilla
del Ln Marta después de muchísimo tiempo
de estar pausadas aproximadamente de
2019 si mal no recuerdo empecemos
entonces con los reportes en la prensa
local sobre esta cuestión y vamos con el
medio el colombiano y Raúl vamos a
empezar con una noticia que salió ayer y
es que la fiscalía levantó órdenes de
captura contra 16 negociadores de paz de
esta guerrilla del Ln recordemos no que
una de las grandes máximas del gobierno
de la izquierda Gustavo Petro es
impulsar esa Paz Total que significa
negociaciones de paz y sometimiento con
todos los grupos armados ilegales que
están en activo en este país no las
negociaciones como decíamos se esperaba
se que inicien este lunes 21 de
noviembre y por ello la fiscalía
revertió estas órdenes de captura
incluidas las de emitidas por
extradición a los altos mandos de esta
guerrilla del lln son personas
reconocidas por el presidente Gustavo
Petro para participar en las mesas de
diálogo y tienen efectos de inmediato y
estricto cumplimiento por parte de la
fiscalía general de la nación el tiempo
Marta el tiempo titula José Félix
laforich ficha clave de Petro para
negociar la paz con el eln Quién es José
Félix lafuri pues es el representante de
los ganaderos colombianos que es uno de
los sectores de la derecha más
conservadora en el país Asimismo es uno
de los representantes de uno de los
sectores más golpeados por la guerra en
Colombia y uno de los sectores también
que se han mostrado más reticentes con
las negociaciones de paz no guerrilleros
y extremistas lo consideran como el Ada
del paramilitarismo en Colombia que son
estos ejércitos irregulares que actuaban
con la convivencia del estado y Petro el
presidente Busca integrar a ese sector
en las negociaciones de paz y desde el
sector de los ganaderos concretamente la
furia ha dicho que va a aceptar el reto
y que contribuirá a hacer efectiva esa
Paz total vamos ahora con el medio el
espectador Marta que dice el espectador
se pregunta es posible la paz con lln y
dice que Cuáles son los elementos que
van a determinar si esto se va a poder o
no llevar a término no dice que pues las
negociaciones de paz son uno de los
puntos esenciales de los primeros cien
días de gobierno de Petro que se han
cumplido precisamente esta semana y que
ya desde bien entrado el gobierno no
Desde esa primera semana Ya empezaron
estos deshielos con la guerrilla no un
Bueno un grupo del ejecutivo viajó a la
Habana para empezar descongelar estas
relaciones que llevaban varios años en
pausa sobre todo con las anteriores
administraciones el 20 de agosto el
gobierno de Petro suspendió las órdenes
de captura y extradición para la sal las
altas cúpulas que permanecían en Cuba y
a principios de octubre estas altas
cúpulas pudieron viajar a Venezuela
después de más de cuatro años no el
cuadro de octubre se oficializaron estas
bueno esta retoma de las negociaciones
que se harán efectivas probablemente
este lunes en mesas de diálogo que serán
volátiles entre Venezuela Noruega y Cuba
además chile y España recordemos eran
garantes de este proceso de paz vamos a
ver entonces qué va a pasar el día lunes
a Marte hay mucha expectativa no
obviamente entre Colombia y Venezuela
por estas negociaciones de paz que pues
esperemos que llegue a una buena
conclusión no que finalmente pues
lleguen a un acuerdo cambiamos ahora de
tema y vamos a repasar un artículo Marta
del final son Times sobre la figura del
General ucraniano que ha estado Armando
de la aparente exitosa contra ofensiva
ucraniana si Raúl nos referimos a Valery
de él dice el ministro de defensa de
Ucrania que su talento radica en haber
aprovechado que Ucrania es el país
pequeño en esta guerra no y de haber
hecho como un poco David contra Goliat y
utilizar estos resorteras mientras Rusia
atacaba con misiles no es un referente
Valerio y salud ni en redes sociales con
un perfil muy valorado por el pueblo
ucraniano y ha habido muchos memes
relacionándolo con un oso no esa figura
que también se asocia al presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin a él se le reconoce esta
exitosa aparente o contraofensiva en la
ciudad de gerson porque el objetivo era
desplegar artillería o de precisión
entregada por occidente para cortar esas
líneas de suministro de Rusia a través
del río nipro no con ataques quirúrgicos
a depósitos de armas a puestos de Mando
y atacando esos puentes clave como el
puente de crimea no que conectaba la
Península con Rusia intentando aislar a
20.000 soldados rusos a él se le
reconoce la capacidad de delegar alentar
la iniciativa entre los rangos
inferiores y además Buscar una
retroalimentación necesaria para
reaccionar ante cualquier eventualidad
no destaca este artículo del financial
Times Así es en Marta esta región región
de gerción pues recientemente liberada
que como también lo decíamos en los
noticieros pues se encontró una aparente
Pues a cámara de tortura cuarto de
tortura y ya son 63 cuerpos exhumados
que muestran signos de tortura Pues por
supuesto por parte de las fuerzas rusas
esto según información de las
autoridades ucranianas y vamos a
terminar esta revista de prensa del día
de hoy en Estados Unidos porque la
prensa de ese país despide hoy a Nancy
pelositas el anuncio el día de ayer de
que dejará su papel de líder de la
cámara de representantes logrado que los
republicanos ganarán la mayoría esto en
las elecciones de medio término de
noviembre no del 7 de noviembre Sí vamos
a empezar con el New York Times que
hacía un artículo de opinión que es casi
una hora a Nancy pelosi que titula Nancy
pelosi como ruda una persona muy tesa y
sostiene este artículo del New York
Times que en 2007 asumió por primera vez
el papel de oradora y ya hablaba de
romper ese techo de cristal por nuestras
hijas y nietas No ha estado 16 años en
la primera línea política ha visto a
cuatro presidentes dos juicios políticos
una pandemia y un intento de asalto al
Capitolio sostiene este artículo de
opinión del new que la historia la
recordará como la primera mujer en
ascender al puesto de oradora y
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes a dos pasos Raúl de la
presidencia de Estados Unidos no dice
que es una lideresa efectiva pragmática
ya que no le ha importado mucho su
imagen pública sostiene además como un
dato curioso que Nancy pelosi no dormía
mucho durante su etapa en la primera
línea y que además funcionaba con
chocolate muchos la subestimaron y
además fue un dolor de cabeza para los
republicanos concretamente para Donald
Trump no ha sido una política muy
querida guarda rencores y además no
tenía especialmente buen humor y además
los demócratas más jóvenes la
consideraban como muy old school pero sí
eso sí dice este artículo de opinión que
hay que amarla u odiarla pero hay que
reconocerla que ha sido una persona muy
pesa Así es una persona regia también es
como dirían Y pues recordemos o sea que
de alguna manera también
a lo que fue a lo que es el gobierno del
presidente yo bailén con su visita a
Taiwán no que la Casa Blanca no estaba
muy de acuerdo que hiciera esta visita
Taiwán porque iba esto a encrispar las
tensiones entre China y Washington
recordemos por la disputa de esta Isla
que china reconoce como suya y no
reconoce la Independencia de Taiwán ella
fue y pues ahí empezaron estos
ejercicios militares entre eh de china
en el estrecho de formosa no entonces
evidentemente realizó estas tensiones y
pues ella de alguna manera ha hecho lo
que lo que ha querido no Marta y también
Esto fue como uno de los puntos
esenciales de la religión el otro día
entre
sistema de Taiwán y toda la atención que
se originó después de la visita en
agosto a la isla no y veremos a ver
Hacia dónde van esas relaciones sobre
todo después del anuncio de relajar un
poco las tensiones entre las dos
principales economías del mundo en todo
caso una señora de 82 años como le
decían sus colegas ha dedicado casi toda
su vida creo que son 35 años que ha
dedicado llegamos al servicio público a
ser política no en Estados Unidos Marta
vamos con vox.com el vox.com Raúl titula
los dos principales desafíos que
enfrentará el sucesor de Nancy pelosi y
es que pues La retirada de Nancy pelosi
deja un vacío también en el partido
demócrata no solo en el liderazgo de la
cámara de representantes que se supone
que va a asumir Kevin mccarthy el
republicano sino también en el seno
demócrata qué va a pasar con ese
liderazgo y este vacío que deja Nancy
pelosi después de como decíamos 16 años
no el sucesor se prevé que sea hakim
jeffreys que es congresista por el
estado de Nueva York y los dos grandes
retos que dice este artículo de vox.com
que tiene o que tendrá Mejor dicho el
sucesor de pelosi son en primer lugar
unir al partido no y es que ha habido
muchas tensiones entre el ala más
conservadora de los demócratas y el ala
más progresista Y en segundo lugar con
tener el avance de los sobre todo de
Cara a las elecciones presidenciales de
2024 Así es Marta como siempre
Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información el lunes